bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine consacrée à l'actualité local
nous sommes le 8 décembre et dans votre
journal aujourd'hui 82 millions de
promesses 82 millions d'euros de
promesses de don pour le Téléton 2014
combien dans les Yvelines premier bilan
de la mobilisation dans le département
pour la 28e édition de ce grand marathon
caritatif en faveur de la recherche sur
les maladies rares 70e anniversaire des
compagnies républicaines de séc sécurité
les CRS Bernard casazenu ministre de
l'Intérieur a fait le déplacement à
Versailles aujourd'hui chercheur au
Laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement à 50 ans en Yveline ILM
lutte contre les émissions de gaz
carbonique François Marie Bréon est
l'invité du journal alors que se
poursuit la conférence sur le climat à
Lima et puis nous reviendrons aussi ce
soir sur le résultat du référendum à
coagère plus de 90 % des votants pour le
maintien des frontières actuelles de
leur communauté de communes les
habitants qui soutiennent donc le maire
contre le projet de super aglomération
incluant Saint-Quentin en iveline
notamment tout de suite le Téléton
quelle mobilisation dans les ivelines
nous sommes en ligne avec le
coordinateur départemental Daniel Bazan
bonsoir bonsoir plus de 82 millions
d'euros de promesses de don au niveau
national 4 millions de plus que l'an
dernier on imagine que dans le
département la mobilisation a été plutôt
bonne également est-ce que c'est le cas
ah très bonne très bonne participation
dans dans les iblines ce qui remonte du
au niveau national et je vais dire sur
le département des iblines chaque fois
il y a la même mobilisation donc une
très grande mobilisation qu'il y a eu ce
weekend le seuil c'est à peu près 400000
€ que vous avez pu collecter l'année
dernière sur les différentes
manifestations c'est un seuil qui sera
dépassé c'est bien parti c'est bien
parti hein normalement on devrait enfin
je pense arriver entre 400 à 500 comme
il y a de 3 ans ça et puis bien sûr il
faudra ajouter aussi les participation
il faudra ajouter les promesses de don
qui ont été faites par téléphone au 36
37 et d'ailleurs les gens peuvent encore
toujours donner la la ligne restée
ouverte par Internet également pour
donner pour le Téléton est-ce que vous
pouviez prévoir alors je rappelle juste
que les chiffres définitifs seront
connus dans la semaine hein vous êtes
encore en train de de comptabiliser le
le le bilan de faire un bilan global
est-ce que c'était tout de même
prévisible cet élan de générosité vous
nous disiez sur ce plateau la semaine
dernière au moment de la préparation il
y a beaucoup de bénévoles mobilisés il y
a beaucoup d'animations qui sont
proposées de plus en plus chaque année
vous vous attendiez malgré la crise à
avoir beaucoup de
dons ben on s'attendait un petit peu à
quelque chose de enfin je vais dire de
similaire une très bonne mobilisation
mais à ce point euh non on est assez
surpris quand même parce que que bon euh
c'est vrai qu'on a eu beaucoup de
nouvelles manifestations mais on
s'attendait pas une mobilisation sur le
terrain aussi importantein donc la
mobilisation du terrain veut dire et ben
très grande mobilisation que le compteur
et ben sera au-dessus de de l'année
dernière quoi là vous êtes en train de
faire les comptes comment ça va
s'organiser pour pour conclure sur sur
la suite l'argent va directement
rapidement partir pour pour la recherche
pour pour la FM comment ça se passe en
ce moment pour vous et ben là on prend
des des rendez-vous avec les
organisateurs à partir de demain et donc
jeudi les premières permanences qui vont
durer ben tout le mois de décembre et
donc là au fur à mesure l'argent est
donc est envoyé donc à et ensuite il
faudra se préparer pour l'année
prochaine merci Daniel Bazan voilà
responsable du télétour dans les
Yvelines nous donnerons bien sûr les
chiffres définitifs dès que la collecte
sera terminée une chose est sûre en tout
cas la mobilisation a battu un record
par rapport à l'an dernier dans le
département également on va rester
encore quelques instants sur cette
mobilisation justement avec cette
opération à rambouiller c'est un bédéton
qui était proposé des dessinateurs se
sont relayé pour assurer les dédicaces
les amateurs eux ont mis la main à la
poche 10000 € seront ainsi reversés à la
FM le reportage de Floran parfait de
Maxime
lemain quelques coups de crayon pour
aider les malades atteints de myopathie
à rouiller des dessinateurs et
scénaristes de bande dessiné sont
réunies pour la bonne cause une séance
de dédicace puis une vente aux enchères
pour lever des fonds c'est la 6e édition
du bédéton une initiative unique dans
les ivelines j'ai demandé l'autorisation
au créateur du bédéton de d'un carque
d'utiliser le nom bdéon puis voilà j'ai
fait j'ai contacté Joseline Bernard de
la médiathèque Florient je demandé si
l'accepter de nous accueillir et
parembouiller très une ville très active
pour le Téléton il beaucoup
d'associations de gens qui le font et
qui qui sont pas peut-être pas forcément
concerné mais directement
personnellement mais qui se sentent
concernés parce qu'on est tous concernés
par
parce qu'il peut arriver à des enfants
les auteurs sont bénévoles l'intégralité
des fonds récoltés sont reversés à l'AFM
l'Association Française contre les
Myopathies Olivier Souillet est l'un
d'entre eux il a même écrit avec son
frère une BD pour parler d'une de ses
maladies sa fille est atteint du
syndrome de Williams c'est une maladie
qui est très rare je crois que c'est un
cas sur 7000 et c'est une déchirure sur
l'ADN de l'enfant et qui provoque donc
un handicap mental et dans 75 % des cas
malheureusement des gros problème de
rein ou de cœur on a écrit ce qui assez
amusant là l'histoire qui nous fait
parler de cette maladie on a choisi de
parler de l'histoire d'un petit dragon
qui s'appelle azuro c'est un petit
dragon qui n'est bleu ou neutre rouge ou
vert et donc il est différent et au
final va être rejeté par les autres
parce qu'il est déjà de couleur bleue et
en plus il crache de l'eau donc n on
utilise le mot malédiction mais en vrai
on pourrait parler d'une maladie le
dessin la BD un moyen de parler de ses
maladie méconnue et de faire appel au
don cette année le bédéton 78 a récolté
plus de 10000 € pour la FM par qu'
l'actualité du jour à présent c'est le
déplacement du ministre de l'Intérieur
Bernard casazenov à Versailles à
l'occasion des 70 ans des CRS il en a
profité pour annoncer un renforcement
des effectifs Mélanie poquet et Patrick
Jacques de
dixm uniformes impeccables garde à
vousou et ins sigle CRS pour Compagnie
républicaine de sécurité créé il y a
tout juste 70 ans le 8 décembre 1944 par
le général de Gaulle et c'est le château
de Versailles qui a été choisi pour
célébrer cet anniversaire un cadre qui
ne doit rien au hasard c'est à
Versailles en effet que la République
accueille ses hôtes de Marc c'est donc
Mesdames Messieurs à bon droit que les
CRS reçurent ici même leur drapeau en
1953 nageurs sauvteur compagnie
autoroutière ou encore section de
montagne les CRS sont spéci dans le
maintien de l'ordre le ministre a ainsi
profité de son discours pour interpeller
les forces de l'ordre avec dans sa ligne
de mire la mort de réy fr militant
contre le barrage de sivin dans le tar
je vous demande donc de participer
pleinement à la réflexion sur l'emploi
de la force que j'ai voulu engager à la
suite du drame de
sivin je vous encourage à poursuivre
dans l'effort de
modernisation à vous doter équipements
et des matériels spécialisés les mieux
adaptés pour bénéficier d'une ensemble
d'une vision d'ensemble des lieux au
cours des opérations de maintien de
l'ordre les plus délicates et également
pour mieux vous
protéger le ministre a ainsi annoncé un
renforcement dans les rang des CRS après
la suppression de 2600 postes en 2012
ainsi je veux vous annoncer que 92
jeunes gardiens de la paix vont
rejoindre vos rangs ce mois de décembre
et vos unités seront à nouveau dotées
d'agents supplémentairire en 2015 j'en
prends devant vous
l'engagement civil et non militaire les
CRS sont rassemblés en plus de 60
compagnies en France dans les Yvelines
la compagnie se situe à
véis et puis en justice c'est ce lundi à
Versailles que s ouvert le procès d'un
homme ayant incendié le domicile de sa
petite amie au clés sous-bois la cour
d'assise doit statuer sur la peine que
devra exécuter abdallahan 25 ans
l'incendie ayant entraîné le décès de sa
belle-mère des fait précéd de menace de
mort un deuxième homme présent lors des
faits qui remonte à mars 2012 comparait
également à Versailles pour
nonempêchement de crime verdicte attendu
en fin de semaine une grève illimitée à
partir du 8 décembre pour les tribunaux
de commerce il refuse le projet de loi
Macron loi sur l'économie pour la
croissance et l'activité qui remet en
cause notamment la composition de cette
cour de justice il est question de faire
siéger des juges professionnels
notamment alors que les commerçants
étaient jusqu'à maintenant jugés par
leur père au tribunal de versaill
William l est allé chercher quelques
explications nous estimons que ces
articles ne sont pas du ressort du
ministère de l'économie mais de la
Chancellerie le ministère de la Justice
avec lequel nous avons un dialogue
depuis le début de l'année sur des
article qui fâch tous nos clignotants
sont au verts sur notre activité sur
notre performance et nous ne pouvons pas
accepter cette mesure de défiance qui en
plus serait totalement préjudiciable à
la la justice économique et donc au
tissu économique et social de ce pays si
le projet de loi ressort du projet de du
ministère de l'Économie pour rejoindre
pour retourner à la Chancellerie il est
bien évident que notre mouvement sera
suspendu l'entretien du jour à présent
c'est avec François Maré Bron bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes chercheur au
Laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement organisme qui dépend
conjointement de l'Université de
versailles-sint-quentin du CEA encore du
CNRS seconde semaine pour les
négociations internationales sur le
climat cela se déroule à Lima semaine
décisive pour beaucoup les ministres
vont arriver sur place demain le sommet
qui va prendre un tournant plus
politique en quoi ce sommet est si
important c'est le 20e sous l'égide de
de l'ONU est-ce qu'on peut en attendre
de réelles avancées l'objectif est de
qu'il a un accord international sur la
limitation limitation des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et en particulier
de dioxyde de carbone ceci dit
aujourd'hui on est dans la cadre des
préparations et la vraie négociation
enfin le vrai accord aura lieu très
probablement au mois de décembre l'année
prochaine à Paris lors d'une réunion qui
sera à plus haut niveau là c'est
vraiment des négociations entre les
ministres pour essayer de se mettre
d'accord sur qu'est-ce qui pourrait être
un accord l'année prochaine on parle de
limiter à 2 degrés le réchauffement
climatique d'ici à 200 si rien d' fait
on sera plutôt à 45 degrés ça veut dire
quel conséquence donc les le climat du
du 21e siècle dépendra entièrement des
des choix qui font fait par les
gouvernements et par les gens de
d'mission de d'émission des gaz à effet
de serre et en particulier du dioxyde de
carbone et effectivement aujourd'hui si
si on fait des énormes efforts on on
limitera le réchauffement de la planète
à 2 degrés mais si on continue comme
aujourd'hui ça sera plutôt 4 à 5°gr avec
des des conséquences très importantes
sur d'une part l'agriculture d'autre
part la qualité de vie des gens et puis
sur le niveau des mers parce que un
certain nombre de calot glacièes vont
fondre sur suite au réchauffement et par
conséquent le le niveau des Meur va
augmenter ce qui a bien évidemment des
conséquences très importantes sur les
littorales vous dites des énormes
efforts c'est-à-dire qu'il va falloir
mettre les bouch et double pour arriver
à un niveau ne serait-ce que acceptable
pour maintenir les choses en l'état
absolument il faudrait par exemple en
France il faudrait que la France arrive
à diviser par deux puis par quatre ces
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
c'est un énorme effort pour pouvoir
faire ça les ONG qui considèrent pour
l'instant que les travaux sont plutôt
lents sur le le sommet qui se déroule en
ce moment est-ce que vous partagez cet
avis complètement il y a pas que les ONG
qui dit ça je pense que c'est un un un
constat général que là où il faudrait
diminuer les émissions en fait elles
augmentent de 3 % chaque année au niveau
mondial hein pour la France les
émissions sont à peu près stables elles
diminue même même légèrement mais au
niveau mondial et en particulier avec le
développement de la Chine euh les
émissions totales de la planète
augmentent de 3 % chaque année donc
c'est absolument énorme et comment on
peut l'expliquer c'est un problème
financier aussi peut-être les États ne
veulent pas mettre suffisamment d'argent
c'est bah non c'est que les gens ils
aiment bien se développer on dit tout le
temps que ce qu'il faut c'est avoir de
la croissance évidemment avoir de la
croissance et augmenter notre cons
d'énergie donc on peut pas d'un côté
dire ce qu'il faut absolument c'est
avoir de la croissance et puis de
l'autre côté dire qu'il faut diber notre
consommation d'énergie les gens les gens
pour vivre ils aiment bien consommer et
donc ça conduit à des émissions de gaz à
effet de ser asse importantes mais les
efforts doivent se faire dans l'ensemble
des pays du globe et c'est difficile
peut-être dans les pays qui sont en voie
de développement de trouver en plus des
finances et de faire des développements
alternatifs c'est pas seulement des
finances c'est de leur dire que que eux
n'ont pas le droit de se développer
c'estàdire que nous on a
chacun chaque foyer on peut c'est
difficilement de dire voilà bon on est
arrivé dans une situation complexe dans
les pays les plus pauvres vous vous
développez mais pas trop absolument et
c'est d'ailleurs ça qui fait la la la
difficulté des négociation est-ce qu'il
faut dire que tout le monde doit
diminuer ses émissions d'un facteur 2 ou
il faut dire que il y a un certain
niveau qui est de consommation qui est
acceptable et donc les pays développés
doivent diminuer énormément leurs
émissions alors que les pays en
développement peuvent continuer à les à
les augmenter donc c'est ça la
difficulté des négociation et c'est pour
ça que c'est très difficile d'avoir un
accord et je suis pas du tout persuadé
qu'on arrivera à avoir un accord on va
faire une petite pause dans cet
entretien pour notre question du jour
micro trottoir êtes-vous inquiet des
évolutions climatiques voici vos
réponses on le craint pas mais on le
voit en tout cas je pense que pour
l'instant ça nous touche pas après il
faut quand même faire attention comme il
disent à la télé ou quoi que ce soit la
couche de zone tout ça euh oui un petit
peu oui c'est vrai parce que le temps se
dégrade aussi bien l'été que l'hiver
nous avons des hivers qui sont pas
rigoureux et des étés qui sont plutôt un
peu pourris je le crains pas à titre
personnel par contre je le crains oui
pour certain certaines personnes qui
habitent sur les côtes par exemple euh
oui raison euh bah par la pollution et
puis pour l'avenir de nos enfant exact
également le craindre c'est inéductable
donc quelque part qu'on ait peur ou pas
peur c'est les choses qui vont arriver
c'est des choses qui vont arriver une
certaine certain fatalisme les les
changements climatiques vont arriver
ensuite quel sera l'amplitude des
changements climatiques vont de prendre
nos actions ensite ce qui est très
important c'est que la vulnérabilité au
changement climatiqu n'est pas du tout
tout la même évidemment qu'on est un
parisien ou qu'on vit par ici en banlieu
parisienne finalement si le climat se
réchauffe un peu ça va pas changer
grand-chose à notre vie par contre ça a
été dit dans dans un des interviews
micro trottoir le la montée du niveau
des mers ben évidemment pour tous ceux
qui habitent près des côtes c'est ça
peut être avoir des conséquences très
importantes et puis il faut penser aussi
à nos petits enfants par exemple qui eux
seront vraiment beaucoup plus affectés
qu'on l' et puis aussi d'autres pays qui
sont beaucoup plus vulnérables que la
France au changement climatique donc
c'est aussi une question éthique de
lutter contre ce ch changement je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheurs pour
leur Laboratoire des sciences du climat
et de l'environnement vous suivez donc
avec attention les discussions qui se
déroulent actuellement et même les
discussions qui ont lieu tout au long de
de l'année d'autant plus important pour
vous que vous êtes un militant
écologique actif vous définissez comme
ça j'aime pas trop j'aime je veux
surtout pas croire que je suis un
écologiste parce que il y a les
écologies il y a plein de choses avec
lesquelles je ne suis pas d'accord
comment pourz vous définir en tout cas
définir votre engagement je suis
militance pour limiter mes émissions de
de gaz à effet de serre mais par exemple
je suis un très grand partisan du
développement nucléaire en France et
donc ça fait moi je suis je pense
que je pense que quand je dis que je
suis favorable au développement du
nucléaire je pense que je suis un
écologiste mais il y a plein de gens qui
sont pas d'accord avec ça bon et par
ailleurs dans ma vie dans ma vie
quotidienne j'essaie de limiter les
transports effectivement en prenant mon
un vélo par exemple pour aller au
travail pas aujourd'hui je dois le je
dois le reconnaître et puis un certain
nombre d'action de limiter ma
consommation ou de pas prendre l'avion
de limiter de pas prendre l'avion pour
aller en vacances par exemple c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites le
nucléaire plutôt que les changements
climatiques en raison des gaz à effet de
serre c'est quoi c'est il faut choisir
entre la peste et le chéra ou vous êtes
per effectivement le le nucléire à
certains certains défauts je pense
qu'ils ont qui ont été largement mis en
avant par les écologistes justement
personnellement je suis plus sensible au
au au problème du dérèglement climatique
que au danger du nucléaire le danger du
réchauffement climatique me paraît
beaucoup plus grave que le Dejour du
nucléaire c'est pour ça que entre la
peste et Coléa bah j'en ai choisi une
mais d'autres personnes chois une autre
vous êtes chercheur vous êtes militant
l'entend ça se traduit comment vous
justement on l'a entendu he vous avez
vos engagements vous limitez vos
déplacements enfin vous avez toute une
une philosophie qui qui se met en place
mais vous organisez aussi des des
conférences des coloques ça se traduit
dans vos travaux aussi ouais je vais la
télé par exemple par exemple c'est une
bonne illustration c'est un moyen et
puis dans mes travaux bah oui
effectivement je dans mes travau
j'essaie de comprendre qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire le changement climatique quels
vont être ses impacts et j'essaie de de
participer en fait il y a pas que moi
qui travaille là-dessus mais j'ess
essaie de participer à faire des
prédictions plus fiables pour pouvoir
vraiment éclairer les décisions qui
seront prises au niveau politique quels
sont les travaux qui se déroulent
actuellement dans dans vos locaux
justement sur quoi vous travaillez alors
il y a des dans mon locaux il y a des
gens qui étudient les climats du passé
et puis il y a des gens qui font de la
modélisation pour être capable de dire
quelle va être qu quelles vont être les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
donc et ça passe par le développement de
modèles sur ordinateur il y aura des des
échanges est-ce que vous êtes sollicité
parce que le prochain sommet se
déroulera à Paris se déroulera en France
on se tourne vers les chercheurs en
France aussi est-ce que vous êtes oui
les ça se tourne vers les chercheurs en
France il y en a qui parlent plus que
d'autres avec avec les politiques mais
oui il y a une interaction entre les
chercheurs et politique et ça passe en
particulier à travers le GC hein le
groupement
intergouvernemental d'étude du climat
qui a remis un rapport cette année qui
est qui qui est vraiment très précis
dans son évaluation de quelles sont les
conséquences du changement climatique un
sommet se déroule en ce moment à Lima
sommet sur le climat le prochain ce sera
à Paris on le disait les et pas
seulement qui sont plutôt pessimistes en
tout cas qui regrettent les évolutions
les discussions qui qui n'avancent pas
assez vite en ce moment est-ce qu'on
peut garder espoir pour le les
discussions qui s'ouvriront à Paris il
faut toujours garder l'espoir il faut le
être riste mais il faut gardereso j'ai
l'espoir je suis pas complètement
confiant mais j'ai espoir que ça va bien
se passer merci d'être venu en plateau
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine 195 pays
ayant ratifié la Convention cadre des
Nations Unies pour le changement
climatique sont donc en train de se
réunir au Pérou pour la 20e conférence
autour du climat reste à voir donc les
avancées possibles d'ici le prochain
rendez-vous ce sera à Paris en 2015
merci à vous une autre information
concernant l'environnement vendredi
matin le point service au particulier de
cquanttin en Yveline qui a signé un
partenariat avec ERDF pour lutter contre
la précarité énergétique sur la
communauté d'agglomération un
partenariat qui permettra par exemple la
création d'un poste d'ambassadeur de
l'énergie
explication ce travailleur social pe
pour être aussi appelé ambassadeur il
aura notamment dans dans ses missions
qui sont celles aussi des autres des
autres travailleurs sociaux qui sont PSP
cell de de comment dirais-je travailler
sur le programme habité mieux et
notamment renseigner commencer à
sélectionner et instruire les premiers
dossiers des personnes qui d'une part
seraient éligibles au programme Habiter
mieux et qui souhaiteraient justement
faire des travaux de rénovation dans
leurs habitations le point service au
particul PSP c'est un service uniquement
pour les particuliers qui sont en
précarité la précarité nous la nous la
vivons lorsque malheureusement les
fournisseurs nous demandent de procéder
à des à des coupures pour imp payé donc
et nous cherchons tous les leviers
possibles et imaginables pour pour
accompagner les les les les
foyers dans dans leur difficultés et
trouver des solutions autant que
possible une toute autre thématique à
présent avec les coagariens les
coagariennes qui ne veulent pas d'un
élargissement de leur communauté de
communes des étans et il le font savoir
ils sont venus le dire lors d'une
consultation publique qui s'est déroulé
hier dimanche Catherine zulato Maxime Le
pour les images
97,90 % pour dire oui au maintien de la
Communauté de Communes des étanss dans
son périmètre actuel comprenant coignère
MPa les brevvières les essardlerois et
le pet en iveline à vé merci Monsieur
Vall une consultation populaire
organisée comme une vraie élection avec
son président de bureau son isoloir son
urnne et ses asesseurs deux bureaux de
vote étent ouverts dont l' en merie je
souhaitais que cette
consultation ne puisse pas être
contestée et donc je l'ai organisé comme
on organise n'importe quelle autre
élection élection municipale par exemple
c'est-à-dire donc les gens votent de de
8h du matin à 20h le soir près de 36 %
des électeurs coagériens se sont
déplacés ce dimanche les habitants ne
veulent pas du projet du préfet de
région d'inclure leur village dans une
grande intercommunalité à 800000
habitants incluant 5 an nveline
Versailles Grand Parc ou encore le
plateau de saclelet 800000 habitants ou
200000 habitants on a rien à y faire
nous on a tout à perdre d'ailleurs qu'en
étant une petite communeel qu'on est on
arrive mieux à gérer que les grosses
agglomérations à chaque fois ça part en
tous les sens j'ai déjà voté pour ne pas
être dans un cont an en iveline il y a
des années et des années et je vois pas
du tout pourquoi nous commur co petite
on irait se mettre avec un grand
ensemble comme ça nous laisse espérer ou
penser qu' nos impôts augmenterait
énormément si on rentrait pour
rembourser les 400 millions qui est de
dette de
de qu Yveline les résultats de cette
consultation populaire qui n'a aucune
valeur légale seront adressés au préfet
des ivlin au préfet de région ce dernier
doit rendre son arbitrage sur la super
intercommunalité à 800000 habitants à la
fin du mois de février 2015 une super
structure qui ne convint pas au-delà des
frontières de coignère la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Yveline et
celle de versailles- grand parc ont
également émis un avis
défavorable un autre vote cela concerne
les élections professionnelles de la
fonction tion publi qui se sont déroulé
en fin de semaine dernière ainsi dans
l'éducation nationale sur l'académie de
Versailles c'est la FSU qui arrive en
tête et dans la police nationale sur
l'île-defance et le syndicat Alliance
qui l'emporte avec une majorité absolue
notamment dans les Yvelines le syndicat
Alliance qui voilà dans un communiqué la
reconnaissance d'un combat contre des
conditions de travail détestables on
termine ce journal avec du sport la team
78 handbal a été expéditive ce weekend
pour le compte de la 9e journée du
championnat de France junior les joueurs
d'Alexandre taer à Plaisir n'ont pas
fait de détail face à Bonny 53 à 27
malgré l'absence de quelques joueurs
majur le groupe a parfaitement enchaîner
cette 8e victoire consécutive lors de la
dernière journée de cette première phase
les ivelinois devront néanmoins
s'imposer et espérer un fau pas du Paris
galaxie pour reprendre la tête de leur
poule c'est un match de travail pour
plusieurs raisons parce qu'on savait
très bien que c'était une équipe faible
donc priori on devait pas gagner le
match mais aujourd'hui il nous manquait
notre rard droit titulaire qui a joué
avec l'INE 3 de Versailles et puis notre
qui est blessé déjà depuis de matchs qui
sera encore blessé jusqu'à la fin de la
première phase donc ça donné l'occasion
de donner du temps de jeu à beaucoup
d'autres joueurs et qui ont l' assumé
puisquon gagne de 26 buts alors qu'au
match all on gagne de 25 là-bas et pour
l'ensemble des résultats du weekend
rendez-vous dans quelques instants avec
Antony R pour une nouvelle édition comme
chaque lundi du 78 sport je vous
retrouve demain 18h en direct pour une
nouvelle édition du journal très bonne
soirée sur TV
fil